so today i want to do something
complicated and that's to take the topic
of sleep like how much sleep
you need to get which is a very debated
topic regularly
and the word guilt guilt is something
that others
impose on you that prevents you
from chasing your dreams because you
feel guilty all the time
and let's get these two guys to clash
and see if i can make a point to you
and hopefully i can take some pressure
off your back fair is that okay with you
so let's get right into so this last
week i'm doing a a webinar it's a
private webinar that i do monthly
and it's for a group of 50 60 70 people
from around the world and one of the
guys on there who runs a
chiropractic practice he does around 5
million a year he says patrick tell me
about sleep
and how you view sleep because this one
professor
who wrote this book which i'm very very
aware of
he says you need to sleep at least a
minimum of seven or nine hours a night
and that's what you need to do but what
do you think about it because you have a
different view on sleep
i said okay cool i said i've seen this
guy he's written a book done great this
book is backed up on a lot of research
he's a professor at uc berkeley
the guy's brilliant he's an expert in
this area however let me try to make the
point of sleep
in a different way says okay tell me i
said so my wife and i were about to get
married we were dating
we gonna meet with a therapist a uh what
do you call it a marriage counselor
right
and a very nice guy recommended through
the church so we're like
really excited about meeting this guy so
i said so you know listen hey here's 200
you know before we get started you know
tell me what is the key to uh having a
successful marriage because you've been
married for how long now he says 33
years
wow 33 years fantastic what's the key to
a successful marriage he says you know
i got to tell you for 33 years
my wife and i have one rule what's that
we never miss
dinner at six o'clock every day my wife
and my kids up until 18 years old we
were supposed to be together at six
o'clock to have dinner
and we believe that's the reason why
we've been able to have a successful
marriage i said okay
i said what do you do for a living he
says i'm a schoolteacher i said okay
what does your wife do for a living
she's also a schoolteacher i said that's
great i said listen i appreciate your
time i put my hand out there shook his
hand he's confused
he's like what's going on i say listen
here's a 200 thank you so much you're
wonderful
we still have 55 minutes left i said i
got what i needed out of five minutes
in the hour and only five minutes you're
wonderful thank you so much we get up we
leave my wife's confused she's like babe
i didn't even get a chance to ask any
questions i said you're right but let's
see what
explain you my point why we don't have
to talk to this guy
she says why i said number one i said
you're not a schoolteacher
neither am i we don't get off at 3 30
every day and have the summer off
and that's not the life we chose to live
we chose to be an entrepreneur and you
if you're going to
marry this guy i'm a guy that runs
businesses it's what i love to do it's
my game it's like marrying an athlete
marrying a politician marrying a rock
star that's on tour marrying an
artist marrying a creator marrying a
pastor marrying somebody
that has a different kind of schedule
that they go so my wife goes
and meets with pastor's wife who's a
realtor and they have a meeting to get
because we're going through all these
different people trying to see what kind
of feedback we're going to get
and she asks my wife of a very
random question she says listen before
you guys get engaged in merit are you
ready to share your husband with the
world
she says excuse me says are you ready to
share your husband with the world
i'm not sure i don't want to share with
anybody he says well let me explain to
what i mean by this
so as you know my husband is part of a
church with 20 000 members
and there's a lot of people that want
his time they want to be around they
need him he sits on boards he does this
he does that your husband's going in
that direction and
he's going to have people that want him
to sit on boards pulled over here that
direction this direction
travels speaking all this are you okay
with that are you okay with managing the
calendar whose birthday anniversary
preparing
the vacation the holidays everything
that's going on you need to put in this
calendar because he's going to miss it
and
because he's got a lot of stuff on his
mind that he's trying to come are you
okay with this are you okay with that
are you okay with him coming home
at night late at 11 o'clock are you okay
with this stuff
and they have that conversation and she
comes back and she tells me about the
conversation right she's like i want
this what was i saying okay what do you
think about it are you okay with that
like what do you think about what you
said
because that's kind of who i am that's
kind of what i'm going to be doing
and the wife was also a realtor so it
wasn't like she's a stay-home mom she
had us
her own career just like my wife has her
own career now we work together she's a
vp
she does things for herself with the
company
i said this makes sense that's the life
the other therapist wasn't living our
life so where am i going with sleep here
so an author writes a book and talks
about how we are better if we sleep
seven or nine hours a night
that may work if you're a school teacher
and you work a certain set of hours
you come home you write books for a
living and you teach a few hours a week
and you have time to go the way you want
to do
but that schedule is not going to work
for somebody that's got a startup
that's trying to build a company that's
trying to get that going
it's just not going to work it's not
going to work for somebody that's trying
to grow their business
where for the first two five ten years
it's a lot of work to survive while
you're building your business
by the way the seven to nine hour
concept also doesn't work if you try to
tell a
mother who's about to have a baby and
has a newborn baby and you tell the
mother
hey i just want you to know this author
said you need to sleep seven to nine
hours why are you not sleeping seven to
nine hours the mother says how dare you
tell me to sleep seven to nine hours
this baby have to wake up every couple
hours and she latches
on me and i have to pump and i have to
do this i can't sleep so i wish i could
sleep seven to nine hours right
and how dare you tell somebody in the
military that's in the field right now
trying to protect the country
and he gets four hours of sleep because
he's got guard duty at two o'clock in
the morning how dare you tell that to
that person right or
somebody that's on a run like an obama
or trump or a
hillary clinton who's on a campaign to
become a president and they're going 18
months and traveling non-stop
shaking cans shaking hands shaking hands
shaking what can i do to earn your vote
what can i do turn your vote what can
well i don't like the way your policy
this this this that
i think you're going to take jobs away
from steel i think you're going to do
this
here we go again same thing i've said
700 times to other people here in
pittsburgh i got to tell you again and
here's what i'm going to be doing
i'm going to please give me a shot let
me or my we're not going to vote for you
get out of our house ok
next home here we go again how are you
going to tell that person that's running
to be a senator governor president
seven to nine hours a night they're on a
run so is he right or is he wrong i
didn't say he's wrong
but it's phases of life so what do i
mean by phases of life
and what does this have to do with the
word guilt because
everybody that ever did anything great
in their lives
they've gone on many runs for example
taking the elon musk
elon musk has been on more runs than
other people have and he's condensed his
time frame for example
elon musk's day is three days to the
average person elon musk's day
one day is three days elon musk treated
to the average person
what a person accomplishes in a week
ilan probably does in a day
what a person accomplishes in a month he
probably doesn't a week maybe even
fewer than a week right a year or two is
like dude
two weeks is what i need on what the
average person accomplishes because he's
constantly feeding himself right
he's on a run presidents are on multiple
runs trump's been on multiple runs
obama's been on multiple runs senate
whatever community organizer
first term second term it's runs it's
runs it's runs you go on
where does the guild come in place here
here's the guilt
the world is going to look at what you
want to do in your life say the vision
is very big
massive and no matter what phase of your
life you're in when you're here
people who are here they're encouraging
you oh you can do it man i'm here i'm a
cheerleader
and then you pastor like hey hey hey
that's a little too much absolutely
why is it too much is it too much or
just because i passed you up
so guilt no no no guilt killed guilt
right at what level does it stop it
never stops
you're making 50 your body's making 70.
you go to 100 000 this guy starts saying
all he cares about is money
you go to the next level you're making a
quarter your body's making
380. okay your quarter is 380. you get
to 500 oh it's just all about money man
i'm just trying about that
right you all of a sudden are creating a
following and you're like hey i was just
creating content all of a sudden you go
over here no no no it's just too much
all you're trying to be is too famous
that that's guilt right
you don't care about family hey you
don't care about your kids hey you don't
care about this all you care about is
money all you care about is success
this is all ways of trying to poke what
guilt
guilt guilt guilt
so one of the guys on the same exact
private webinar that i was doing monthly
webinar that i was doing said patrick
i'm having a hard time with life i said
what do you mean
he says i'm just not enjoying my life
right now
i said how's your marriage he says it's
not the best but uh
you know it's not that good i said is it
bad no it's not really bad it's but it's
not good it's not like we have anything
that's kind of boring use the word
boring i'm like
in every word you want to use a marriage
boring but sometimes marriage does get
boring right because
routine routine routine routine routine
some excitement right okay
uh how about business it's doing great
how about money best ever how you doing
physically healthiest i've ever been
i said so what makes you happy he says
it's very weird i'm not a drinker but
the only time i've been happy lately is
the fact when i go away and
i have a drink and i'm scared because
drinking is making me happy
i said what are you escaping and he
starts kind of talking and says well you
know i'm growing at a 30
rate but there's a lot of people that
are growing at 100 rate
and he's going through all this other
stuff i said why are you letting the
world make you feel guilty buddy
i said look you know there are certain
things you can never do
what do you mean by that i said look
trump
became a president and he beat bloomberg
bloomberg wanted to be a president
never became a president but bloomberg
built a massive media company's worth 70
billion
trump's only 25 billion trump won
in this game bloomberg won in the media
game
bloomberg won in a business game okay
you go back to a different level okay
bloomberg won a media game elon musk is
winning in the wealth game
look at where elon musk is at right now
and that's a race there's competition
it's fun
but the moment you get into too much
comparison that turns into envy you have
to really come back right
so sleep guilt here's how much you
should
sleep should you don't know what i'm in
the hunt
for i'm in a run you're working too hard
this is not good
guilt killed killed killed killed should
and guilt
combined together is catastrophic
combination should and guilt shouldn't
guilt
you should killed killed killed you
should
guilt killed killed you know what
eventually happens
you can't enjoy your life so here's what
i said i said look
my my expectation in life isn't
perfection
i'm not trying to perfect life i'm never
going to perfect life my expectation
isn't
to be perfect for my mom and dad it's
never going to happen not for anybody
it's never going to happen however i'm
going to give you the flip side
my standard is to come through for the
people i love the most my standard is to
lead
my standard is to improve my standards
to get better but i have to also enjoy
my life
the other night i was sleeping with my
son and my middle son is just such a
sweetheart of a guy
and it's me him and my oldest son who i
love when we get into conversations
one of my favorite people to talk to my
older son my youngest son i just love
talking to these guys right
and uh my younger son says hey daddy
we're off tomorrow
i'm like really yeah he says aren't you
the boss
i said what do you mean you're the ceo
aren't you said yeah
why don't you take tomorrow off and come
and spend time with us daddy i'm gonna
call is that guilt
he never puts that guilt thing on me
like you never do that it's not putting
the guilt thing on me
i'm like you know what i rarely do this
i said okay i said buddy i can't do that
because i've got conference calls board
all this other things that i have to do
but let me see what i can do so i go to
work all night i'm thinking about his
comments
to me so i come to work i do my thing i
tell everybody after 3 30 i got to leave
i finish it up at 3 30 i leave i go pick
him up i surprise him
i say go put your swimsuit on they put
their swimsuit on we go straight to the
park they run around zipline all this
stuff they meet all these other kids
that are playing with them
30 minutes later we went to the beach
i'm in my swimsuit
we're running around on the beach i'm
making a sand castle with my daughter
she's
all over the place daddy i got sand on
me this is disgusting daddy i don't like
sand on my hands daddy please
homie homie homie homie homie homie
homie she doesn't say hold me she says
homie homie homie homie i'm like bro bro
bro bro
should i pick her up we go in the water
she gets her hands no no it's too
daddy water's too close she's just
climbing on top of me and we're
wrestling we're having a good time my
son is all over me
um we're a mess we get in the truck
we come back to the house everybody's
wet the truck is a mess
bring him back took two hours had a
freaking incredible time with these guys
magical time with these guys come home
shower with them
they put their clothes on then they went
to a soccer practice and i went to miami
to have a meeting at soho house with the
mayor suarez of miami
and bunch of influencers top 50
influencers and tech and
krypton all this stuff in miami to have
a meeting with them but i didn't do it
because i felt guilty
i did it because i wanted to do it so i
can go spend time with these guys
i chose to be an entrepreneur to create
a business where i have the kind of
wealth that i have in control that i
have so i can do some of these things at
times
but often too many times people use that
as an excuse of every day i'm working
too hard i need to sleep
i'm not talking to the excuse makers
there's millions the majority of the
world is just looking for an excuse to
sleep more and work
less the majority this is not that
message for you
this message is for the person that's
watching saying pat i'm in a freaking
hunt
do not let the shoulds of the world and
the guilts of the world
confuse you of chasing your dreams and
don't get caught up
comparing yourself to everybody because
once envy goes in you will not enjoy the
process
work like you've never worked before
improve stay curious stay hungry keep
coming up with new strategies all that
other stuff
but still figure out a way to enjoy your
time with your family have a blast
get the massage if you need to get the
foot massage go do the exercise
all of that stuff and by the way you can
do all that crazy stuff together as well
so now
i told you it wasn't gonna be easy i
hope i've made my point to you
of combining sleep the shoulds and
guilt the here's what you ought to be
you're not you're not being good enough
of a parent all these other things that
you're doing
hopefully those two make sense to you
so if i made sense to you there's a
video i want to recommend to you it's a
talk i gave
i don't even know what the timeline is
maybe six years ago seven years i was on
an rv i lived in about an rv i
went you know 10 000 miles from la to
miami to toronto to san francisco back
to la
and i gave this talk and one of the
parts like 25 minutes called the dna of
an entrepreneur if you've never watched
it
it's going to give you a lot of clarity
what i talked about in today's video
click over you to watch that
with that being said have a great week
everybody take care bye